[Music]
so let's go to kayla in indianapolis
indiana what's up kayla how are you
doing
hi guys how are you
great what's up
so
hopefully you guys don't shred me too
hard for this oh you're your friend
i know
so
we did the right thing we sold our car
that we were making payments on we sold
it to carvana
and they gave us about 8 200 and then we
put that towards another used car a
beater as they would call it
so we ended up spending about 5800 out
the door on this nissan armada it looked
great on the outside we had test driven
it and it was doing all right um except
the check engine light was on my husband
asked about it and the guy said it was a
battery and he could get it off so
um i drove it home it drove a little you
know like a used car and so we called
about it the next morning and it
wouldn't even start so we called the guy
he said take it to a mechanic and he
would work out a deal with us on getting
it fixed that sounded officiated but my
husband's like okay so we took it to the
mechanic
turns out the subframe is completely
ruined there's a hole in the exhaust
pipe that's leaking water onto the
subframe making it even worse just
terrible to drive unsafe
um and he's just told us it's completely
toast so my husband went into the
dealership today talked to them and he
laughed him out of the dealership
basically do we have any room to sue
them i mean what can we do like i'm
putting my trust in god fully and i i
know it's going to be all right but i'm
i'm a little furious and i want to see
if we have any room to do anything about
this
okay so
there's no way we're gonna shred you
over this okay this this stinks i'm
sorry
yeah we're out about 5800 bucks the guy
told us he inspected it then he told us
he didn't my husband recorded him saying
he did get it inspected but he couldn't
find the inspection report somehow
so you can go to small claims court
you can sue them and i can't give you
legal advice but you can contact a
lawyer in your local area and go down
that road if you'd like to
okay um i would recommend adding up or
getting some really clear
um
written
right you've learned the importance of
that
clear
written um a written contract about what
legal advice is going to cost what going
to small claims court would look like
what settling would look like i mean
i don't know what the
recording laws are in indianapolis is it
a one-party state or two-party right
it is a one-party okay okay so
all that to say is you can go down that
road
it's
not maybe he gets a letter a demand
letter from an attorney and he writes
you a check and gives you your money
back maybe that's what happens
probably not that's what i've read
usually
would happen if he were found to be in
the wrong probably not
okay
um
let me just say if i'm you yes i i've
got buddies who are attorneys i worked
at law school for years so i would have
somebody write a letter and i'd pay them
and they'd write a letter and see what
happens there
um okay
i also would be prepared both
spiritually and psychologically and
emotionally
for this to be a painful 5 800
lesson
yeah
that um we
we you knew driving that car off the lot
that something wasn't right in it
it was a big car and armadas are cool
and they're big and we got a good deal
on it and
now you know
i'm never driving a car off the lot with
a check engine light on i'm never
driving a car off the lot without an
inspection in my hand i'm never right so
you learned all these things and if you
look on the on the arc of your life how
old are you
i'm going to be 30 in september okay in
10 years 15 years 20 years 5 800 for the
lesson you've learned here because this
is going to impact how you buy a house
it's going to impact how
how your kids go to college it's going
to impact everything because you learned
a hard lesson here
um
and everyone i know has made them dave's
made them with millions right you've
made one with 5 800
this will be a lesson that pays for
itself over and over and over again i
don't want you to beat yourself up over
this okay yeah i'm kind of i know you
are
you know cried out yeah because this
sucks we we
we only have 2 200 in our savings
because we're in financial peace right
now yes
and you know we and you and your husband
y'all are good people you would never do
this to somebody
and you just ran into a scumbag an
absolute
cheater scumbag who ripped off a young
family and it hurts because because you
don't even know people like that
and often when you run into someone
who's just a scumbag like this and and
you've heard me say this probably before
yeah you lose trust in other people but
more importantly and more damaging you
lose trust in that beautiful brilliant
person that you see in the mirror every
morning
okay
yeah and it's a 5800 lesson and it sucks
and it hurts and hopefully you can find
a lawyer you got somebody at your church
that'll write you a letter and maybe
this person coughs up your money and
it's all over and you learn that lesson
too
but i don't want you to lose trust in
yourself this hurts and this is hard but
you will work through this and i know
y'all are busting it so hard ah the
stings man
kayla i'm so sorry you're going through
this it makes me mad yeah i'm pissed for
you
and i would definitely push
on this dealership to to make this thing
right and do all the things that john
said that was really really well said
but a lot of this stuff is going to be
well the contract says as is and when we
sign that thing this is what we got and
so like john said we're not here to beat
you up we love you and i just want to
help you move forward and make sure that
you guys have a car to drive are you in
a situation where you don't have a car
now
so my husband has a car but we have a
toddler and an infant i'm on maternity
leave right now i have to get my toddler
to school at nine my husband has to be
at work he's a general manager
of a hilton so he has to be there to
open the doors or to manage all his
employees early in the morning then he
would have to come back home get my son
take him to school then go back to work
and it just interferes with a bunch of
things so we were trying to get another
car yeah you guys have a church
community right now
we do yeah we're in a wonderful church i
would get plugged in with them i would
talk to one of the you know pastoral
care folks over there and say hey here's
our situation is there someone who just
let us borrow a car while we get on our
feet or would sell us one for a thousand
dollars a beater to get us around just
to get through the situation that's one
of those things where having a community
like that can be so so powerful to walk
with you through this journey
and i know that's humbling and that's
hard and that's annoying and you did
this thing right kayla you did it right
you sold your car you were gonna pay off
some debt i know and that's that's what
sucks is i i know i did it right and i
and i got taken advantage of you did
y'all got y'all got burned and you
didn't listen to yourself are you ever
gonna make this mistake again
you know i told my husband
i said i don't like that that is in my
phone and i don't like how he answered
that question and he's like well he said
it could either be 50 50 chance so i
mean i should have just trusted my god
always always trust your gut trust
always kayla is trustworthy kayla is
trustworthy
this scumbag used car salesman selling
cars being like nah bro it's cool is not
trust your gut and don't trust check
engine lights ever ever